[Applause]
[Music]
senate democrats narrowly passing that
sweeping climate and economic package
over the weekend putting the president
and his party now on the cusp of what
has been a big legislative victory just
three months before the crucial november
midterm elections join us right now to
discuss what's in the bill and what it
means for business former representative
donna edwards is with us of maryland and
kevin o'leary investor and of course
venture capitalist cmbc contributor good
morning uh to both of you this is a
seismic uh piece of legislation has huge
implications uh for business uh and the
climate i'm gonna go to kevin because i
i want to start
not on a negative side but i know that
you have problems with this bill and i
want you to spell out what they are so
that we can we can have a debate about
it
well let's start with the fact it's a
very partisan bill there's no agreement
on any of these policies we know that
with certainty by looking at the vote
number two
and i understand everybody's having fun
with this naming it anti-inflation is a
joke this is going to be very
inflationary almost immediately because
we're printing
billions of dollars so it's not going to
help there at all and it's it's sort of
a build back better inflation bill
because it has some derivatives of the
initial big vision so you've got a
situation and i'm not into politics i'm
into policy i'm an investor i'm trying
to figure out what happens next should
this pass and what does it mean to me as
an investor what do i what do i do with
this policy and so i ask myself well
nobody's happy so if i think about
what's going to occur in the midterms if
the idea here was to get this bill
driven through to show accomplishment of
this administration and again i'm
bipartisan on this because i know with
certainty
any administration loses momentum
midterms so it's important that this
administration got something done but is
this going to solve inflation inflation
right now is around the voters around
food and energy energy is rolled over a
bit that's good and of course anything
can happen until november 8th but the
rest of this bill
highly inflationary ain't going to help
going to be lots of unhappy people and
in various close races whether that be
senate or otherwise
i think what occurs and again this is
speculation on my part but i'm going to
invest on this premise
this is going to be the last legislation
this administration ever gets to put
through after november 8. one of the
reasons
pelosi went to taiwan which she knows
and she's going to be a very successful
politician it's over she's not going to
be speaker after this midterm election
and she made her move and i applaud her
for it it was very gutsy but bottom line
is this is last chance for romance on
policy and then it's total gridlock and
that's a good thing
donna edwards what do you say
well i think kevin has a lot of wishful
thinking there um this is a big win for
the president and for biden and i think
as you described it comes on the heels
of several really big uh policy
victories over this last month on top of
that adding you know jobs into the
economy which um is outpacing anything
that we've seen and so what the bill
does is it provides consumers with
something real and something tangible
if they want to add a new heat pump like
i do then they'll get a tax credit for
it these credits will extend over the
course of about 10 years and so it's not
like putting all 370 billion dollars
into the economy right now
for business it includes things like
manufacturing credits to incentivize uh
domestic manufacturing particularly on
on high technology which is what we need
to to do to wean ourselves off of
off of china as a resource again spread
out over 10 years
it's the largest investment in the green
economy that we've ever had uh
particularly when it comes to electric
vehicles um to the previous bill making
sure that we have um an infrastructure
that supports that this is a sweeping
victory for the president and uh for
democrats in congress and it's something
that they'll be able to run on donald
let me just come back to you before we
go back to kevin for a second though
what do you think the long-term
implications of our going to be on both
the the corporate minimum tax do you
think that there's going to be a
long-term or short-term implication in
terms of jobs there
but bottom line andrew on this is does
it make the united states of america
more competitive in the g20 or less
competitive there is no question to that
outcome
less competitive the whole idea about
corporate taxes is corporations create
jobs for people in america 65 percent of
jobs are created by small business and
look whether you're a billion dollar
income business or you're not the more
you tax the more you suck out of the
system the less jobs are created the
less competitive you are this is a very
bad policy for corporate competitiveness
and you really want to stay in the
middle of the pack of the g20 and create
a corporate in terms of corporate tax
where we are right now this slowly
grinds it up we ran around the world
telling everybody 15 was a great idea
nobody followed us we did it to
ourselves we hurt ourselves it's a
self-inflicted wound bad policy
well donna hey it's brian sullivan i
mean listen it is maybe it's bad policy
maybe it's not we're going to find out
in a couple years because it looks like
some of the medicare pricing provisions
don't actually begin until the year 2026
so that's four years out so it may
reduce
some inflation but but but then
not not this inflation but how important
is it for the democrats to just have
something to sell to the american people
with a by the way a catchy name
well look i don't think i don't think
democrats want to just anything i mean
these are significant uh policy
improvements and you talked about the
medicare
medicare spanning over you know the next
four years look it took us some time to
implement the affordable care act and
people embraced it um i think that these
medicare provisions are particularly
important for our seniors who need to
have
you know lower cost money into their
their pocket and will last for the long
term and so the idea that it's not
injected into the economy or isn't done
right now
we're playing the long game here and the
long game suggests that we have to lower
these prescription drug costs um it
doesn't disincentivize uh investing into
new drugs and
manufacturing new drugs i think it's a
really strong it's a strong provision
it's a strong bill and those who are
arguing against it
and especially against corporate tax
provisions are not in the mainstream at
all small businesses already probably
pay uh that on average anyway it's the
really big guys who get away with paying
nothing and this puts a cap on that i i
don't think anybody's gonna argue
against it donna cause it's gonna pass
so it's it is here and you know if you
if you didn't like it too bad right
you'll get none and like it
because you're going to have to deal
with it but i think the counter argument
would be well you're going to you're
going to cap these prices for seniors
which means then
the industry is just going to raise
prices for everybody else so it's going
to be extremely inflationary for private
insurers
because you're gonna have price controls
on the medicare side i don't know if
that's gonna happen but that's where
some of the criticism has come
yeah i don't i don't know about that i
mean i think that what will happen is it
actually could um serve the you know the
purpose of decreasing those prices look
the veterans administration uh the
largest health care system in the
country already negotiates prices uh for
veterans this would add a new uh
you know sort of pricing and negotiation
for uh for seniors and i think that
there will be a demand down the line
downstream um to negotiate prices
overall i mean it's ridiculous insulin
drugs that people use drugs that have
been on the market for decades and
decades um
increased prices for americans where
abroad they're paying a fraction of
those costs
hey uh donna i want to get your view on
this and kevin as well
senator cinema on on carrot interest
what what happened here she's from a
state that does not have a huge private
equity or even real estate uh business
she gets a lot of money from the private
equity
industries though she has not been
public about why she wants to keep
carried interest it seems to be a
relatively bipartisan issue in that
president biden and former president
trump both wanted to get rid of carrot
interest how how is this industry so
powerful well i know
it's not that it's so powerful
on capitol hill um lobbying and they've
been successful thus far it's
unfortunate that senator senema in order
to get her support for this sweeping um
climate legislation traded on uh on
carried interest and so that's going to
see another another day um but i don't
know why she's carrying their water
she's going to have to explain that to
the voters of arizona
what were you saying bottom line is this
what is the most successful private
equity sector in the united states in
terms of what it does for business it is
the most successful on earth why mess
with it why change it why change
anything the economy is on fire half the
provisions in this fail are unnecessary
and only inflationary including things
like giving tax credits to to ev cars
right now when you can't even buy one if
that's not inflationary that heat pump
you're getting for free that's just
missionary
if you're against corporate welfare and
you're against this sort of industrial
policy why have an industrial policy
which benefits you personally
it of course it does i'm admitting i'm
being transparent but you're telling me
a sector that i compete with let's say
chips gets free money and i'm a taxpayer
paying for it that's another incentive
the incentives drive the economy the
incentives and private equity have
driven the most successful private
equity sectors
these incentives don't change the
returns these incentives don't change
the returns they were they changed the
returns and how much money people like
you get to pocket
andrew i take risk that's what i do
if you want to take risks with your own
money god bless you and pay capital
gains on it but if you can take risk
with other people's money why should you
be getting capital gains rates on that
money because i manage that money and
people trust me to manage it and that's
why they do oh my goodness there is no
legitimate argument for
carried interest uh the loophole there
is no legitimate argument for it and
kevin can try to make that um but it's
not real and the fact that the industry
has been able to um to keep up their
lobbying successfully on this what about
millions of jobs i mean you're making
money off of money that's not even yours
wait a second we've created millions of
jobs in this country we fix broken
companies every day we look all around
the world for opportunities to attract
capital to america to invest it here how
many politicians actually create jobs
when this sector gets attacked i get
offended because we do really hard work
to build our economy and we've done 65.
kevin a week ago you said you didn't
want money to go to the chips because
because you didn't want corporate
welfare for that group and you said look
how profitable they already are look how
profitable the the private equity issue
this is the wealthiest industry in the
in the country in terms of the people on
an individual basis andrew when in
america do we punish success when did we
start doing that when do we
disincentivize risk of capital why are
you attacking not because it's not your
capital
not your capital
asking you to uh to pay a fair share is
not a punishment kevin no matter how you
try to characterize do not assume that
raising taxes reduces deficit all it
does is crush economic activity that's
been proven out many many times we'll
let this thing play out but when there's
bad policy there's bad policy can i be a
referee here can i be a referee here a
little bit just jump in uh don i want to
ask you this let's talk about taxes but
let's talk about taxes for the
individual part of this bill
is they're going to double funding more
than double funding for everybody's
favorite agency the ira i happen to love
the irs and i and i hope i just embraced
them someday but here's the thing
they're going to increase part of the
revenue projections are increased audits
donna i mean those audits are going to
have to come on the middle class and
upper middle class because there's not
enough rich people to make much
difference with these audits so i mean
to say it's not going to raise taxes
is technically accurate but is it isn't
it a little bit disingenuous if somebody
make it 100 grand now starts getting
audited every five years
well i first of all i don't think that's
going to happen we have to recognize
what is going to happen that's what
they're saying
the irs has been neutered over these la
over the last decade and i think that
putting money back into enforcement
making sure that people pay what they
they owe and that they're not cheating
uh the system is is important for all of
us and nobody should get away with that
and so i don't think it's going to mean
increased audits for the middle class
but it is going to mean uh that you know
what happens is you try to make sure
that you have systems in place so that
people follow the rules and don't
require audits and i think this is going
to make more people follow the rules
i think there's a big issue there
because 65 of the economy of family
businesses you're now empowering the irs
to chase the majority of those families
who are the essence and the backbone of
our economy and the assumption that
they're all cheating is ridiculous most
people want to pay their taxes look i'm
not against having more efficiency in
the irs but giving them 80 billion
dollars to chase people that are
actually the backbone of the economy
doesn't sound like good policy to me
either if you like that video where do
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe